hello everyone my name is james powell
and this is my pi data 2021 presentation
today is thursday october 28th and this
is a pre-recorded presentation
and so without further ado i present to
you
how to be a pandas expert
when we talk about developing expertise
in a particular tool it is generally not
the case that expertise is gained
through studious memorization of an api
studious memorization of details but
instead through judicious understanding
judicious discovery of what the core
concepts what the fundamental intuition
is underlying these tools
when it comes to a tool like pandas the
api is quite large there are many
different methods there are many
different data types and there is a lot
of detail but i hope you'll see in this
presentation that there is just a few
core concepts in python sorry there is
and i hope you'll see in this
presentation that there is
just one core concept that really brings
together almost all of the pandas api
and all of these details when you look
at a tool like pandas that core concept
is the index and index alignment
through this presentation we'll try to
motivate what the index is all about and
why it's so important and why it's so
intimately related to everything that's
going on in pandas and we'll do that via
some live coding and so i will share my
screen with you
behind me you'll see my screen
i'll hide in the corner here and we'll
jump right into what we want to cover
we're going to be going through these
notes in a live coded fashion and bear
in mind these notes will be available to
you after we are done with this
presentation in both code form and pdf
form but to get us started let's talk
about
why panda is in the first place why do
we even bother with pandas because in my
opinion pandas is a very one-dimensional
tool there's basically only one reason
to use it and there's a pun in there too
and if you think about all the different
reasons that you might have landed on
using pandas
there are a lot of reasons that might
come up but they're not very good
reasons for example maybe you want to
use pandas because you
like the python dictionary in the python
list and you're looking for something
that's even less convenient and even
more perplexing for example here we can
see this thing called a pandas series
and it prints out a little bit
differently than the list and we can
iterate over the contents of it using
inner items but we get that like 0 1 2 3
4 the numbering of the rows i don't know
why that's useful so maybe we'll just
unpack that into a variable you don't
use or we could iterate over this
directly but i don't really see what
this is getting us over a list or more
likely if we're using pandas we're
familiar with the pandas data frame and
this kind of looks like maybe a
dictionary of python lists or maybe a
bunch of lists stacked next to each
other or some sort of matrix and again
we can iterate over this thing but when
we iterate over this thing we get
something really weird we get the column
names how is that useful to anybody so i
guess we could find it or rows but i
have no idea what this is giving me this
is giving me one two three giving me
it's the row and each one of the columns
or iter items that's kind of like a
dictionary right and this gives me
each of the columns independently i
guess i can throw away the column name
and then i get the columns i don't know
why somebody wants that or i could do it
or tuples and there i'm starting to get
kind of close to something i can deal
with tuples lists dictionaries i
understand those things because if you
compare something like a pandas data
frame or a panda series to a the
built-in data types in python the python
list the python set the python
dictionary
i'd say in terms of just
straightforwardness the built-in types
really went out here we have a python
list and it's just a bunch of numbers in
some structure that we can iterate over
and we can iterate over and get each of
the individual numbers and do something
with each of the individual numbers here
we have a python dictionary and it's
just some sort of key value pairing some
labeled set of these values and we can
iterate over each of the labels each of
the keys or we can explicitly do it with
the d dot keys or we can go over each of
the individual values or we can go over
the pairing of the keys and the values
that seems pretty straightforward in a
very simple api
and so if we think about why we might
use pandas clearly it's not for the
strange namings of all these things it
or tuples
it or rows
maybe it's for the really bizarre errors
that come up when we use pandas
here we have a panda series and it seems
to be just a couple of numeric values
and here we have a pandas data frame and
it seems to be three
sequences of numeric values zero one and
two and we can multiply these but we get
a bunch of nands on the end how is that
useful maybe i'm multiplying in the
wrong way kind of like matrix
multiplication isn't commutative and so
here
we can see that it doesn't actually
matter the direction in which i multiply
these you know s times df1 df1 times s
doesn't make a difference maybe i'll
introduce another data frame into the
story and we'll see if anything
else happens so here we have a different
data frame and if i add that to the
first data frame
i get a bunch of nands at the beginning
well that's no big deal because at least
i can just drop the nands i guess that's
what i do all the time with pan is just
drop nands because they're popping up
all over the place and what i could do
is i could pretty much join these and i
get a bunch of nands there i could guess
i could drop them let me introduce
another data frame here and this data
frame doesn't look all together too
dissimilar from the second data frame we
were looking at and let me try and join
these and when i join these it says
cannot join with no overlapping index
names hold on a second
joining should just be like stacking
them next to each other kind of like
what that plus operation seem to be
trying to do
and so why is it telling me no
overlapping index names what does the
heck does that even mean
and if we are unlucky enough to ask one
of our coworkers
what does this mean why is pandas giving
me this error they will helpfully tell
us oh the answer is you got to rename
the axis just rename the axis to
something on both sides and then the
join will work as you expect and you'll
say
what does that even mean how is that
helpful that's total nonsense rename
axis my goodness
and so
if you compare that to our built-in data
types like the list the list just makes
sense here we have a list called x's
here we have a list called ys and these
represent some opaque collection of
items that we iterate over so if we add
them together that is some sort of
sequence level operation or rather some
sort of container level operation it
concatenates them and if we want to use
some special syntax for this we can
unpack these lists into a list literal
so we can concatenate them in a
different fashion and if we actually
want to add them up lining them up well
we just do an explicit for loop and we
can see exactly oh you're zipping the
x's and the y's and you're finding each
one of the pairs of those values and
you're adding up those pairs that just
makes sense there's no rename axis in
this my goodness and the dictionary also
makes a whole lot of sense here we have
a dictionary with some key value
pairings
we have another dictionary we can use
this unpacking syntax to merge these
dictionaries yeah merging dictionaries
you take all the key value pairings of
one or all key values for periods of the
other and there's some order of
precedence for if there happens to be an
overlap and if we happen to be using
python 3.9 we can even do this with just
the pipe syntax
and if we want to do some sort of
arithmetic operation then we can
explicitly do that arithmetic operation
we can take the keys of one of these put
them into a set takes the keys to the
others put them into a set find the set
union of those and then look up the
values and then create a new dictionary
with the keys and the values
attained by once from one side or the
other and if we don't see one of these
key value pairings in one of the two
sides that we're adding we can
substitute a zero value by using the
dictionary.get and even if we go into
the python standard library and look at
the other collection types it provides
they just make sense like the
collections.counter totally makes sense
it's just kind of like a dictionary
except it specifies that the values
have to be some sort of integers and so
or some sort of numeric value some
counts and so if we have two counters
like this we can add them together and i
guess that makes sense you add the
corresponding count so if you have three
a's and one and four a's the other you
have seven a's in the result and we can
even find the intersection or the unions
of the counts and we might scratch our
head a little bit and say okay that's
stretching it a bit what does that
actually mean but it actually kind of
makes sense because if you had two bags
of things that you had counted maybe
sometimes you want to say what's the
minimum that i can rely on having in
either bag or what's the max micro rely
on having in the other bag and if we
think a little bit these map to our
intersection our union our pipe and our
ampersand operators
and so that doesn't quite give us a good
motivation for why we want to use pandas
maybe it's because pandas is so
frustrating we end up doing a dot values
all over the place just to get back to
say a numpy and d array something that
we know how to deal with for example
here we have a series and it seems to
contain some newer values and we have a
data frame and it contains some other
numeric values and we can multiply these
and we get all nands what is going on
here if i drop nan here that's not going
to be helpful for me at all
because
oh my goodness i'll just drop the whole
thing here um okay let me see what
happens if i take
this data frame that i started with and
another data frame and i add them
together
well they seem to be about the same size
these two data frames but when i add
them together i get all nands as well oh
boy this drop net trick is not going to
help me because i'm going to have no
data left over and so instead maybe i'll
just just throw away the pandas parts
just do the dot values here and i guess
i could do the same thing with my s dot
values and my df one dot values except
broadcasting error oh geez
i guess even in the
numpy universe our life isn't that easy
and if we ask our helpful co-worker
they'll say oh you got to use a new axis
you've got to add to the axis here in
order to satisfy the broadcasting rules
and you say you know that is just not
helpful you are speaking a different
language i have no idea what you're
talking about
and
if it's the case that you manage to
coerce this to work and you dot values
your way to something that actually
gives you the answer that you want but
you still want to have that data frame
for whatever reason you can always take
the result and stick it back into a data
frame and so i guess that's not too bad
it doesn't seem like a very compelling
reason for us to use pandas
maybe it's that in addition to that dot
values to basically run away from pandas
we can do a dot reset index to kind of
stay within pandas and throw away
whatever that index is because that
seems to be the source for our problems
and i guess that might be a compelling
reason to use pandas that we can just
dot re set index our way to success and
so for example if we have a data frame
that looks like this and we want to
group by that a column and that a column
happens to be unique values so we should
see exactly the same number of groups as
there are rows we can sum all the values
which in this case isn't going to do
that much it will sort by the a values
and if we can take that and say add it
to another data frame and that other
data frame is going to look like this
well we can see that again we ended up
with a bunch of nand values except for a
tiny little sliver there drop now that's
not going to help but you know what i
don't have to do a dot values and make
this work i can at least reset the index
on one side and then it's giving me
something that kind of looks like what i
want or in the group i might be able to
pass a keyword argument to tell it don't
set the index
and maybe it's because pandas is so
unpredictable in terms of what it will
give us when we perform an operation you
know good tools should be guessable we
should be able to write some code and
have a sense for what it's going to do
before we run that line of code pandas
doesn't seem to be the case because even
with something simple like trying to
figure out how many rows i get when i do
an operation with two pandas objects
i can't guess what that's going to be
like if i have these two series which
both contain four values and i sum them
up
well okay the result has four values
that's not too bad but if i swap them
out with these two series which still
have four values i'm getting as a result
six values
what
they're four values and four values that
i'm adding together and i'm getting six
values in the result and if i swap it
out with these two series that
themselves also have four values i get
eight values in the result my goodness i
can't even predict how many how many
values i'm going to get from adding
these two things that would never happen
with the python dictionary that would
never happen with a python list i can
explicitly talk about oh this is how i
want to combine these two structures and
i can see immediately from that code
which might be a little bit clumsy
but i can see immediately what's going
on and so this is a pretty pretty
terrible reason why you might want to
use pandas because we have very little
predictability over what's going on
well maybe what i might want to do is
just reset index myself to success here
and so maybe i'll just take this result
and i'll reset index
and then i end up with
something that kind of makes sense to
have that extra column called index
that's not very useful so even better
than reset index i'll reset index and
i'll throw away the index completely
just just throw that in the garbage not
helpful at all you're really not adding
anything to my life
maybe the reason that we use pandas is
because it makes very weird and
incomprehensible distinctions in its
library
for example
if we have a data frame and we want to
go into that group by and we want to
group by this column here that is no
longer
unique values but actually it's only two
values two are false we want to find all
the places where a is true and all the
places where a is false we want to group
by and do a sum that works but if we
want to do another operation like say
the kurtosis
then that's not built into the group by
we can't do group by dot curt so we
might do a group by.transform and that
seemed to give me this result one two
eight rows what on earth is going on
here or maybe we'll do a dot apply and
that gives me a and b like that that's
bizarre and maybe eventually we'll come
back to
doing a
dot ag
and that seems to kind of give me the
right thing but why on earth did they
create transform dot apply and dot ag
why not just have one why not just make
this easy for me and what on earth does
this even mean
maybe it's the case that we use pandas
because it is full of minor conveniences
that allow us to eliminate more or less
about one line of code
for example if we have a series we could
take that series and we could shift it
by one value or we could shift it and
subtract it from itself or we could do
series.sum or we could do series.mean or
series.skew and kurtosis and between you
and me i don't even know what skewer
kartosis means sure kurtosis is what the
scaled fourth moment of a distribution
no clue what that actually means but i
do know that i could have just imported
this from scipy.stats
and i could have just used the numpy and
dra and i could have just used indexing
on the numpy and d array to chop off the
first element if i'm going to drop the
nan anyway what's the difference and i
could have just done a subtraction that
seems much clearer do the subtraction of
these elements removing the first
element from one and going up to here
this should be the last element on the
other and for the rest of these
operations.summon.mean
already provided by numpy and skewing
kurtosis great i got to eliminate one
scipy.stats import doesn't really seem
like a very compelling choice
for or very compelling reason for why we
choose pandas
maybe it's because we have this data
frame thing in pandas which seems to be
the ability to work with grouped data
sets and it only costs us about 250 000
lines of code of complexity in the
pandas library to have pretty much a
dictionary of numpy and d arrays here is
a data frame like many of the data
frames that you've seen before and i
guess i can do operations down the data
frame like i could sum i could create
the column sums and i guess that would
probably take me as many as two or three
lines of code maybe a dictionary
comprehension if i want to do this in
pure numpy with a dictionary and a
dictionary comprehension
and i guess i can sum across the columns
and maybe that might take me just maybe
one more line of code and for all of
this complexity that i'm removing group
by there's a group line in the inner
tools module isn't there all i have to
pay is 250 000 lines of additional code
complexity in one of my dependencies
that's not such a high price and by the
way 250 000 lines of code yeah
if we take the panda's source code
and we take
every single one of the files in the
pandas directory in that source code and
we put the results into a pandas series
after executing wc-l on that to find the
length of each of those files we can see
this is every file in the pandas source
code distribution
and how many lines of code
are in each one of those files and i
don't care about all those files because
some of those are tests and so maybe
that's not that helpful maybe i'll index
this thing and remove any one of these
entries where it's from a testing
directory or the test directory okay and
that gives me a mask and i'll take that
mask and i'll do a dot lock operation to
just pick out the files that don't
belong to anything that's in that
testing or test directory and so that's
what's remaining and i'll take that
result and i'll group that result by the
parent most directory and the suffix of
the file so i get something that looks
like
the following where i have every file
and every location rather
and its suffix and i'll unstack this and
fill with zeros if there doesn't have to
be anything so i can get a sense for
what's there
and so here i have all the dot c files
boy that's that's quite a few lines of
dot c code
and look p x d code p y x code but if i
look at that dot pi column 86 000 lines
of code in the core and 69 000 lines of
code in the libs and if i sum this
then it'll give me the sum
on
you'll see a per file name basis or full
profile type basis 194 000 lines of
python code and if i sum this all up
i'll see
this is a lot of complexity that i'm
paying for and what am i paying that
complexity for a bunch of code that
makes no sense that i'm struggling with
all the time does not seem like a good
bet because here's the thing here's my
data frame and i want to update that
data frame i do this all the time to
python lists the python dictionaries to
numpy and d-rays so i'll do something
very simple i'll just say go into that a
column go into the zeroth row of that a
column and just multiply that value
times ten or maybe multiply that value
times a thousand or ten thousand and it
seems to work except if my data frame
seems to be very slightly different with
just one more column i get a setting
with copy warning 250 000 lines of code
and i still have no idea what's going on
this does not seem like a compelling
reason to use pandas and so our goal
here is to try and figure out
how do we become a pandas expert by
understanding the core concepts and i
think the core idea is
understanding why we use pandas in the
first place
and so we are not here to talk about
numpy so let's talk about numpy why do
we even bother with numpy in the first
place well that makes sense python list
is slow numpy is fast as part of our
conceit for this here we have a simple
little timer and we'll time some code if
i sleep for one second it takes a little
bit more than a second to run and you
can see our timer is not a great timer
but it's approximately a decent timer
well if i use pure python my python list
that i'm familiar with and i create
two
python lists of size 100 000 it takes
about a half a second and if i do the
same thing with the numpy api it takes
about
a hundred times less
okay
so
that's a benefit fast code is is is good
code
and if i take these operations and i
compute their dot product i can see it
takes about 0.02 seconds to do the dot
product and pure python i can totally
understand what's going on here take
each of the values of x's each of the
values of ys pair them up
multiply them and then sum the result
that's a dot product
but if i do the same thing with numpy
you can see
i get
an incredible improvement in the speed
that's 70 times faster 70 times speed up
on some code that's that's definitely
worth it and one of the core ideas that
i have when i think about numpy and i
try to motivate why i use numpy is numpy
provides us with the ability to do
numeric operations faster because numpy
is a restricted computation domain
namely it's the ability for us to put a
manager class around some sort of python
data
to intermediate between the python layer
of our code and some code that has
implementation perhaps in c or fortran
because we have that implementation
barrier we can do things like unboxing
values make them contiguous have exact
control of memory eliminate dynamic
dispatch and as a consequence we're
getting 100 times speed ups 80 times
speed up 70 times speed ups we're
getting a significant increase in the
speed of the code and the reason that we
should think of numpy in terms of this
restricted computation domain idea is
it's this domain and we have to stay
inside that domain or we lose all that
performance because if i take my
python dot product and i apply it to my
numpy data and i cross the boundary of
that domain it's actually slower than if
i had done that in all pure python
this restricted computation domain idea
is very important because it gives us
that fundamental motivation for why do
we stay within numpy why do we stay
within pandas because it is a domain
which has intermediated between the pure
python level and some implementation
level
as long as you stay in that
implementation level everything is fine
but if you cross that boundary you're
you're in you're creating
a number of additional costs that are
going to be worse than if you just
stayed on one side or the other of it
it's a domain which gives you certain
restrictions to allow you to do
computations faster and in fact if we
think about what numpy really is it's
really just an interpretive view of raw
memory here we have a numpy and dra and
we can dig into that numpy and dra and
see that this is actually raw memory at
that memory location that we're
interpreting in some fashion we're
saying some block of memory at this
location contains n64 values and we
interpret it to be three values in a
three
in a one dimensional structure just
three values
and
we have some mechanisms by which we can
in linear time sorry in constant time
move through these values some striding
mechanisms associated with these and all
of these pieces fit together when we
think about numpy it's also that numpy
provides us with something that's
missing from python which is a vector
matrix
mathematical type in other words if we
have our python list our python list is
some sort of opaque collection of items
so when we add two lists together
because they're opaque collections items
just a bag of stuff that we iterate over
well the addition of these two should
just be all the stuff that we had over
it should just concatenate or if we
multiply something that's a list
and it's just a bag of stuff well then
we're just saying oh give me that bag of
stuff three times over repeat this thing
whereas if we do the same on a numpy and
d array we get what we expect to be
mathematical operations vector
multiplication vector addition we're
saying oh this is not opaque we know
what's inside this it's numeric values
and when you add these two together
match them up and add them together when
you multiply this go to each value and
element wise multiply these okay that
kind of makes sense
and if we think about what the python
list provides us versus what the numpy
and d-ray provides us the numpy and
d-array provides us with some sort of
fixed size dynamic shape higher
dimensional structure and it is
important that we talk about
dimensionality because this is related
to one of the core concepts that we have
to understand about pandas namely pandas
is one dimensional data even though the
documentation says two-dimensional data
it isn't really it's really like-aligned
one-dimensional data well let's think
about what that means here we have a
python list and a lot of people would
say oh this is a two-dimensional list
and the reason they'd say it's a
two-dimensional list is well if i want
to access any one individual element i
need two coordinates and so you could
say two coordinates to access something
makes it two-dimensional
but in fact this is not really
two-dimensional because while i can
access just one row i can't access one
column natively without performing some
sort of looping there's no native
first-class way to access one column and
so it's yeah there are two coordinates
for every value but it's not a
two-dimensional list it is a nested list
it's not that i'm providing two
coordinates once i'm just providing one
coordinate that gives me a nested
structure and providing another
coordinate so this is two operations not
one operation and so each layer of that
list only takes one coordinate it's just
that this is doing two lookups on two
lists
and additionally it's a nested structure
so something like this makes total sense
in python here this is a list that
contains lists and one of those lists
contains lists which contains lists and
if we think about what this contains
here we can get one value this way we
get one value this way and if we think
about this we can say well
this doesn't have uniform dimensionality
some of the layers of this some of the
rows of this have additional dimensions
and that doesn't make sense because when
we think about the dimensionality of a
structure
the dimensionality of a structure tends
to be a property on the structure as a
whole and it tends to be a scalar
structure it's that everything is
three-dimensional everything can be
accessed via three coordinates this is
nested data this is data where depending
on where you are in the structure the
lookup may require
some number of coordinates that are
different from the number of coordinates
in another layer so it's not quite a
two-dimensional structure in fact a
python list is never two-dimensional
data it is always one-dimensional data
it just has the ability to sometimes
nest data note this structure here
completely reasonable completely valid
python list
no mathematical meaning impossible to
represent to numpy what does this even
mean mathematically this is a matrix
where it's kind of sticking up one one
off the side of one edge and it's nested
in it's like a hypercube in one part but
not the rest no actual mathematical
meaning
whereas
if
we think about what a python list gives
us that a numpy and array doesn't give
us python list gives us the ability to
update the size it's an indirection
between the actual storage of this data
so i can take a list and i can append
items to the end and it just works and
if i have two references in that list
both of them get updated whereas if i
have a numpy and d right sure i can do
an h stack but
if i have two numpy and d arrays that h
stack is not updating that numpy and d
right directly because a numpy and d-ray
is a interpreted view of memory and
because it's an interpretive view of
memory it's a raw block of memory
somewhere with some interpretive layer
on top of it
well i can't just resize a raw block of
memory who knows what might be behind it
the only that i can do is reallocate new
memory
copy things over
and if i have two references then i've
got to keep the old one around and so
only one of these references to this
numpy and d array reflects this
amendment
what we can see from this is that a
numpy and dra
cannot be resized but it can be reshaped
and if we look at these two non-binaries
you'll see two completely separate
blocks of memory and so here this gives
us an a very clear reasoning for why we
use numpy numpy gives us a fixed size
dynamic shape structure
which is a nice correspondence to our
python list which is fixed shape dynamic
size fixed shape meaning always linear
always one dimensional numpy is a
mathematical type
the python list is some sort of
container type
and numpy gives us fast code that's
great but we're not here to talk about
numpy we're here to talk about pandas so
let's talk about x-ray instead because
we're definitely not here to talk about
x-ray
let's say we have some sort of real
two-dimensional data like image data
image data is definitely two-dimensional
because i can access any one pixel in
that image data by two coordinates and i
can rotate it and the data means the
same thing and i can look at any
columnar or row slice or diagonal slice
of this and that's a meaningful
operation and the whole thing is
homogeneous this is definitely
two-dimensional data pictures are
two-dimensional
and you can see if i put this into a
numpy and d-write i can access one
individual row
i can access one individual column
without having to have any additional
mechanism
and you can think that there's many
different ways for me to perform these
operations but ultimately the numpy and
dra is some way for me to take
n-dimensional data in this case
two-dimensional data
and give me the ability to operate with
it now the reason why i might want to
introduce x-ray into the story is if i
have this data
even though
rotations of this data don't really
change what the data is as a human being
i want to be able to access state data
like a human being so i want to talk
about the x-coordinate and the
y-coordinate because that's something
that i want to have in my code that'll
be something that people will understand
they'll be able to look at that and say
oh yeah x equals three and y equals four
and they'll be able to map that to some
physical reality of where this data was
actually captured and so what i'll do is
i'll take my numpy and d right and i'll
lift it up into an x-array data array
and i'll name the dimensions and so now
i have the exact same numpy data but
i've said oh one of these dimensions is
the x dimension and one of these
dimensions is the y dimension and then i
can do things like select x equals zero
that is incredibly clear what this means
select x equals 1 and y or x equals 0
and y equals 1 one value and i get
here a array of a single value but that
makes sense and i can select arbitrary
subsets of this arbitrary sub squares of
this or diagonals of this select x
equals 1 and x equals 0 and y equals 1
and y equals 0. x array is quite useful
gives me the ability to access my data
to look up that data by some sort of
human metadata namely what the name of
the coordinate is and you can think
when you're using numpy sometimes you
have to transpose things because the way
in which the data was read in wasn't
quite the way in which you
your code is going to operate on that
data and you have code that hard codes
oh look up this axis and this axis and
this axis and you need to transpose it
to make that work but with xray you can
name these
axes you can name these dimensions and
so any code that you write
absent consideration of any sort of
performance consequences of this but any
code that you write can just refer to
those axes by name and just work
irrespective of whether the data happens
to be transposed or not
if i happen to have this data and it was
captured on something with a coordinate
system
like this is physical data that i'm
capturing on some sort of detector and
that detector has tick marks 10 inches
15 inches 20 inches i can add a
coordinate system as well and that
allows me to say select my data using
this coordinate system don't select the
first data value that was captured
select the data value at 15. that is
very useful and with x-ray i can even
say select the data at x15 y13 and if
you can't find that exactly look for the
nearest value and i can even say select
the data at x equals 15 and y from 12 to
18 and if you're missing data in between
do a linear interpolation incredibly
useful because somebody looking at that
says oh yeah 15 i know exactly where i
put that marker on my detector when i
was capturing this particular image
very useful
and
it is the case that when we want to work
in numpy because we want to stay within
that restricted computation domain we
will sometimes invent artificial axes
that do not represent certain aspects of
the individual data items for example
here we have not one file but multiple
files and we put this into one larger
structure with one additional dimension
one additional axis representing the
file name that we're operating on and
one of the requirements here is that
every file has to be exactly the same
size they have to be three by three and
they have to have a shared coordinate
system okay fair enough but every file
was captured on the same coordinate
system from 10 to 20 on some stepping
and i just have the file names
associated with each one of these files
and that allows me to do things like say
select x equals 15 y equals 15 from the
file called a dot bitmap oh incredibly
useful i can actually understand what
the heck this is doing x-ray is a very
useful tool if i have raw mathematical
data and i want to interact with that
mathematical data with some additional
metadata that makes it human
understandable namely the dimensions and
the coordinate system on those
dimensions but we're not here to talk
about x-ray we're here to talk about
pandas so y
pandas
here i have a pandas series and if i
look deeper into a panda series i will
see that under the covers a panda series
has a pandas array it has a dot array
here and this dot array is
one small level of indirection from the
raw values that are stored if i go a
little bit deeper in this i can probably
even pull out the numpy values stored
within and this one level of indirection
the panda's array this extension array
idea gives me the ability to do things
like masked integer values because
obviously if i have a floating point
value
i can store nands to represent data's
missing but i can't quite do that in
integers because there's not really an
unambiguous inband encoding for that and
so i need some sort of out-of-band
encoding i need some sort of masking
mechanism
well the thing that we call the index
that is probably the most interesting
thing about pandas is just like that
coordinate system on x-ray it's a way
for us to refer to the values and a very
common indexing that we might use is
daytime indexes
this isn't just value 7 2 0 negative 5
and negative 4. it's seven that i
captured on the first of january two
that i captured on the second of january
and so on and if i look at this panda
series i can see it consists of the raw
mathematical data that's being stored in
this pandas array and some index that
helps me figure out how do i translate
my human understanding of what this data
or where this data is captured to
where the data is actually stored in
memory
and i can do things like say oh give me
the value at the first of january give
me the value from the first of january
to the end of the year or to whatever
has been captured and that works and
it's a lot more convenient than having
to do this in terms of raw matrix
operations especially if i'm working
with multiple data sets and those
multiple data sets weren't captured over
the same time span but there is an
overlapping time span that i want to
consider
it turns out that the pandas index is a
way that we label data
in order to access it and in order to
give additional meaning to manipulations
that we perform on this data
and so here i have a panda series and
you can see i've indexed it with values
that appear to be some sort of
measurement from negative 20 to 20 with
some stepping associated with them and i
can say give me the value at 0. and here
this is giving me the value at label 0.
i can say give me the values from 0 up
to 3.
and you can see it gives me the values
from the label 0 up to the label 3 which
is just that value 0. now i can look at
what happens if i ask for the values
from 0 up to 3 from the panda's array
well the panos array doesn't have any
indexing on it so this is the physical
values from physical locations through 0
to physical location 3 versus the values
from label location 0 to label location
3. so one of these gives me 3 and one of
these gives me 1. well it turns out that
one unfortunate thing about the panda
series is that square bracket notation
can be a little bit ambiguous
because
if i change this indexing very slightly
you can see if this indexing
is an integer indexing then suddenly
this square bracket seems to have given
me the values from physical positions
here to physical position 3
not from the label 0 to 0 to 3 and if i
make this floating point values i can
see something kind of similar to what i
had before it's working on the labels
again but you can see this mismatch
occurs
now
pandas has addressed this and it's the
case that we have an unambiguous
specific way for us to access the
contents of a panda series we can use
dot lock if we want to use the labeling
if we want to use the index and we can
use dot ilok if we don't want to use
labeling if we don't want to use the
index and you can see the dot lock
because it uses the index is going to be
affected by the index the dot ilock will
not be affected by the index because it
doesn't use the index
and if we were to compare the dot lock
the dot ilock rather
the accessing not using the index to the
dot array lookup we'll see largely they
give us something very similar the
output looks a little bit different one
of these gives us the series with the
original index the other one gives us
the raw values but in terms of what
values they access they access the same
values
there are a couple of questions might
show up here one why does that square
bracket indexing by itself act the way
it does and in a moment you'll see why
that actually makes sense and another
might be
hold on a second this is using an
interval notation when you're doing the
slicing and almost everywhere else where
i see an interval notation in python it
doesn't include the endpoint but this
seems to include the endpoint
why on earth
is this including the endpoint if i ask
for label 0 up to 3
using dot lock it gives me
rows
if the indexing happens to match up for
that it gives me everything up to and
including 3. that's a little bit bizarre
but before we take a look at that
before we think about that
let's change our index very slightly
if we go into
this structure and we change the
structure very slightly so it's a
index letters from a to d
then we can actually begin to reason
about this the dot lock operation
uses the index
to figure out what value you want
but the index
doesn't have to be numeric values
because the index doesn't have to be
numeric values it could just be labels a
b c d e it may be the case that if we
want to include the next value we want
to include that endpoint where we could
have just done a plus one
on the
dot lock on the normal slicing indexing
to go up to and including that point we
cannot do a plus one on any arbitrary
index this is not well defined you can
see
the dot lock including the endpoint
makes total sense because the dot lock
is using the indexing and the indexing
is not necessarily
going to have some sort of ordering
associated with it and it's not
necessarily going to have some sort of
successive operation and as a
consequence that dot lock has to include
that endpoint otherwise you would not
really necessarily have a way to include
that endpoint what does plus one mean if
there's a date time index one day one
hour one minute
and if we look at our various indexing
we can see some interesting things about
the various ways these indices may
operate here if we ask from a to the end
or from a to c depending on that index
it may give us many different things if
our index looks like this where there's
a bunch of nonsense in between well
it'll give me all the stuff from a to
the end or from a to c with that
nonsense if the a and the c are repeated
you can see it's pretty smart it gives
me from the first a to the end or from a
to c from the very first a to the very
last c
but if they're interleaved
i get this weird error cannot get left
slice bound for non-unique label but
that actually kind of makes sense this
isn't a bizarre crazy error this is
saying you're asking for the values from
a to c but there's an ac and ac
which a did you want which c did you
want which age do you want which c do
you want do you want the very first a
and the very last c
that's not quite clear and if the index
is in sorted order then there's an
unambiguous choice we can have but if
the index is not in sort order then this
there may be some ambiguity here
many of the errors that you see with
pandas are actually about warning you
against ambiguities which do not have
well-defined semantics
and it turns out that these ambiguities
can arise on in different circumstances
depending on the index there are in fact
many different types of indices that you
may encounter there are your simple
range indices and if you look at that
range index and you look under the
covers you can see well you know there's
a dot array and it's just some values
from zero to four
zero up to and including four you know
there's a range index that looks like
this and you can see it's some sort of
stepping
there is an integer 64 index and you can
see that integer 64 index is just a
bunch of integers that represent you
know this integer maps to this
particular physical location there's a
date time index and you can see you can
have a date time index with a set
periodicity with a set frequency
and you can even change what that
frequency is you can have an interval
index that says oh if you're looking for
a value between 0 and 2
then this is or between zero and one
between one and two between two and
three or between zero and two and
between two and four with this
particular notation for which side is
closed you have that there's a period
index if you're looking for a value in
q1 of this year and q2 of this year
there are all these possibilities and
this may lead you to believe especially
if you do a dot array on all these that
the index is data but the pandas index
isn't actually data it is something that
is convertible to data it is something
that is often backed by data but the
panda's index is actually
mechanism and here's my proof for it
if i have a range index with all the
values from 0 up to 100
that's what it looks like
if i have a range index from all the
values up to whatever that looks like
and this is actually data
i would run out of memory i can't store
all the values from zero up to
one quadrillion up to one quintillion
there's no way for me to store that
memory and yet i can create this range
index the range index is a mechanism by
which we take a human description of
where the data is the label the key and
we map it to the physical location you
can think a range index is a very simple
way because whatever you asked for in
terms of
the
you know give me the element at 24 it
just gives that back out to you or if
it's starting from a different starting
point or if it has a different stepping
it just does a little bit of arithmetic
in order to figure out what the
corresponding physical location would be
if there happens to be some logic here
and when you look at the index the index
has some information about itself it
knows things like whether it contains
duplicates it knows things like whether
it is in sorted order and whether the
values are unique because that's going
to determine whether operations that use
the index like that dot lock are well
defined or not
the index is centered around a method
that you might call or it's sent around
this method get lock and get lock says
i'm going to translate for you what one
key
turns into when you want to find the
physical position so get lock called
with 10 for this particular index says
oh the value 10 on a range index from 10
up to 20 stepping by five well that
value is going to be at
zero the position zero this is the
translation between the human
description of where the data is and the
physical description of where the data
is in some underlying storage and
there's also operations on this like
slice locks if you say give me all the
values from 10 up to 13 with the human
description of it oh that's equivalent
to a slice of zero to one on the
physical location of the data and
there's other things like getting
indexers you can give it another indexer
and it can tell you how to find these so
if you say give me all the values from
10 to 30 stepping by five you can see
it'll say oh get the value at the zeroth
position the value at the first position
and those negative ones indicate that
that data is not located in the original
data set and so that's maybe why we
might need to do some nand filling for
those negative one positions
the indices in fact support a bunch of
common operations and a common api so
here are a bunch of different types of
indices and if we iterate through each
one of these indices
and we take a look at whether it has a
get lock whether it's monotonic whether
it's unique whether it has duplicates
they all do
and if we take all of these index types
and we look at all the methods they
support minus the ones that begin with
underscores and
we
find the intersection of all of these we
can see it's actually a fairly large
surface area for the methods that the
common indices that you interact with
implement it's more than just is
is monotonic there's is monotonic
increasing is monotonic
decreasing there's quite a bit that
these commonly support unfortunately
this does make it somewhat difficult for
you to create your own mechanisms for
looking up your data to extend the index
especially if you want to do something a
little bit a little bit unusual here is
an attempt to do a very simple symmetric
index an index where you can say
you know what according to my analysis
the human's description of where the
data is located is invariant on whether
it's on the plus side or the negative
side if i say negative 2 that's the same
thing as asking for the element of 2.
and i want all my logic to represent
that so somebody can understand oh it
doesn't matter if you ask for the
negative 2 element that's the same thing
as the element of 2 but i don't want to
double the amount of data that i store
especially since i'm just storing
redundant data so i'll create a
symmetric index it's kind of like the
n64 index that says oh if you give me a
particular location that i need to look
up i'll just take the absolute value of
it and give you that corresponding
location and this very simple code
actually mostly works here's my index
one here's my series you can see that's
my symmetric index in place and i can
ask get lock give me the element of 2
give me the element negative 2. and it
says oh that's corresponding to the
element of position 1 and i can even do
my lookups and you can see it gives me
the same value the unfortunate thing
however is if i had another series
object and i wanted to add these
together it won't add them an index line
fashion there's a lot more mechanics
that need to be done in order to make
this working so there's a bunch of nands
here and that kind of makes sense
because this series two had a bunch of
locations which the other one didn't
have but you'd expect this one location
to be filled in in this one location to
be filled in and they're not and in fact
it turns out that it's a little bit
tricky for you to
create your own custom indices because
there's a lot of mechanism that happens
behind the scenes to make these indices
work
i want to show you what happens when you
do a simple
s1 plus s2 operation in pandas and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to use the
sys module to set a tracer i'm going to
trace every function call and every
function return i'm going to put the
results into a pandas data frame with
the file name the line number the name
of the function and the depth in the
function call stack and so i'll take
some very simple code like take this
series here and this series here and add
them together and let's take a look what
these two series look like they are not
that unusual they're just two date time
index series
where
one of them is from the first of the
year to the fifth of the year and the
other one is from
the second of the year to the sixth of
the year so they're slightly offset well
here i can perform this operation and i
can look at the data frame that results
from this and let's take a look at this
data frame and there are a lot of
function called 677 function calls that
i was able to capture from just that s1
plus s2 look at all the function calls
that are less than a depth of five you
can see these are all the function calls
that are happening i'm doing a new
method then i'm doing a bunch of checks
okay that kind of makes sense aerith
method i guess that's launching me into
the plus and you can see there's quite a
bit that's happening here ensure wrapped
if daytime like there's a lot of extra
mechanism in pandas
and if i look for all the function calls
that are relative
in terms of the file location to core
indices you can see there's about 155
calls into something related to the
index here and so there's quite a bit if
you need to extend your own indices this
is one area where i think pandas could
be improved make it easier for you to
extend some of these built-in structures
like you're making your own custom
indices
but
critically
our goal here is not to extend indices
to become a panda's expert expert at
using pandas and so
just to get a sense of what this index
is we can think it is operative metadata
it's metadata
that has well-defined semantics in terms
of data operations that we use it's
metadata that's used as part of some
operation let me show you what i mean by
that
if you have a panda series you can
actually attach metadata to that panda
series like the source of this data or
the author of this data using the dot
adders
and this will actually be preserved
through operation so here we have two
series two data sets and they have
different sources and they have one
stored the author the one stored the
date when it was captured and you can
see i can look at these data sets and i
can look at what those attributes are
and i can perform a group by one of
these data sets and if i perform that
group by in some operation you can see
oh
it appears that i have lost my metadata
well that's a shame and different
versions of pandas are better and worse
at or getting better at preserving this
metadata but you can see
when you do the group by pandas like i'm
not quite sure to do with that metadata
and it threw it away
if i were to take these two series and i
were to add them together you can see it
preserved the metadata but preserve the
metadata of the first series if i add
them in the other direction it preserves
the metadata of the second series and
that's not something that you usually
consider oh that the order of operation
is going to affect where the metadata is
but if you really think about this this
kind of metadata has no well-defined
semantics in terms of the operations of
the series in other words
if you add these two series together
what do you do with the metadata do you
merge them well if you merge them what
does that mean to merge them if there's
two sources and they're each strings
with the file name do you
return a set of the two file names do
you return a list of the two file names
do you take the bigger of the two file
names if there are two dates what do you
do if they're two authors what do you do
if one of these
had a numeric value another one had a
numeric value like number of bytes do
you sum those do you put those into a
list what happens and so in the absence
of well-defined semantics in terms of
this metadata pandas is doing the best
they can do and then the best they can
do is just grab the metadata from one
side or the other
now
the metadata that we have on a panda
series is not just the adders but
there's also a field called dot name
and you can see that the dot name of
these two is not being propagated when i
add these different versions of pandas
may or may not propagate the dot name
here in some cases you may get the name
of one side or the other but the core
idea here is there are operations that
we can perform on this panda series
where the metadata that we have for that
panda series namely the attributes and
the name of that series may or may not
be preserved and it's not well defined
whereas when we think about the pandas
index the panda's index is always well
defined in terms of the operation
because the operations are defined in
terms of the pandas index and so the
pandas index is actually metadata that
will be preserved through
transformations that you perform on that
data because those transformations will
be defined in terms of how they change
the index
and so it's some sort of persistent
metadata that's very closely tied to
that data
well if that's the case what are the
rules of the index well we're here to
talk about pandas so let's talk about
numpy
and if we talk about numpy we want to
figure out what are the rules of numpy
we might think what are the rules of
numpy broadcasting or the rules of numpy
promotion
and so an example of trying to discover
what it means to develop expertise via a
look at the rules we can say well if we
wanted to understand numpy one of the
things we want to do is understand what
are the rules of the numpy and d array
so if we have a numpy and data that
looks like this four values we might be
curious what are the rules which the d
type of this data set changes where
something that is integer data may turn
into non-integer data for example
if we take these values and we take the
logarithm and then exponentiate them
we get floating point values back out
and it doesn't round trip back to what
the original result is
and this might not seem like such a big
deal floats integers doesn't matter but
if we look at these floating point
values and we see is every value in this
thing equal to the first value
no because they're all different numeric
values if we
mesh grid this and see is every value
equal to every other value no
is every value close to every other
value
no
these are four distinct values 992 993
994 995
but if we had some promotion happen
behind the scenes and these turned into
floating point values then
the first value is equal to all the
other values
every value is equal to every other
value
and every value is close to every other
value because as a consequence of this
promotion
we lost the ability to store the
distinction between these four values
because you can see 2 to the 53 we're
probably working with ieee 754 double
precision floating point values we don't
have the ability to precisely store
that last digit and so you can see that
the rules of promotion will be very
important if we wanted to learn about
numpy now i don't want to go into the
rules of precision for numpy but i will
say that unfortunately this is one area
where
you may want to use a tool other than
pandas because the rules of promotion
and the associated loss of position it's
very easy for this to happen in pandas
if we have these two series here that
both contain the values 992 to 995 but
they're differently indexed
and we ask these two series do you
contain the same values they definitely
do
we ask if the indices are the same
they're not
we sum these two values it'll do an
index align sum
which will pop up nands where things are
missing
as a consequence of filling that nan
well we can't store a nan in an integer
array so it's going to promote
everything into float64 and we might say
oh but there's a dot add call what's a
fill value so maybe i could fill with an
integer zero and it'll preserve
everything integers but no it won't and
so unfortunately pandas will sometimes
get you into that floating point
into that floating point dtype
even if the api suggests that it might
not have to
and as a consequence this loss of
precision can sometimes happen a little
bit more easily in pandas than a cannon
on pipe but our goal here is not to talk
about numpy
uh
promotion
operations
and it's not to talk about numpy
broadcasting but let's talk about numpy
broadcasting because it'll help us
understand what index alignment is this
thing that we've mentioned a couple of
times so far
if we think about numpy broadcasting
it's about taking two dissimilarly
shaped data sets and figuring how to
match them up so that an operation
performed on the two of them makes sense
in other words if i have x's and y's and
x's looks like this and y's looks like
this i might say how do i add these two
together well y's has two values and x's
has two levels so maybe i add one of the
values from one to one loves the other
and one of the values on the other one
to the other layer or the other level of
the other one when i add this together i
get a broadcasting error cannot
broadcast these operations together and
if i swap out y with something that is
two by three it still complains to me
can't broadcast together but if i do
something that's 3 by 4 it works
why did you decide that a 3 by 4 against
a 2 by 3 by 4 worked but a 2 by 3
against a 2 by 3 by 4 didn't work and if
we ask our coworker well how do i make
this work with say just the two values
they'll say oh use new axis
right what what the heck is nux is all
about well
it turns out that if we understand the
rules of broadcasting all of this makes
sense and many of the errors that we
might run into
will be very clear why they are the way
they are and things like new axis will
actually make sense the motivation for
them will be fairly clear
note however
when you're becoming an expert at a tool
like numpy or pandas it is not
guaranteed that the rules will always
make sense it is not guaranteed that the
rules will actually drive intuition or
conceptual understanding because one
thing that you might wonder is i had
this very nice box drawing character
here and you might say he used a dot
format that's one of the first times
i've seen him use dot format since f
string was introduced why on earth to do
an f string and i might say well if you
take a
dashed value and you multiply times 40
well you get a line of 40 but it doesn't
look that nice if you use the unicode
box strong's line horizontal it looks
much better if you put this into an
f-string everything works and so here i
can have an f string with a new line
before and after but the rules of the f
string say you cannot have backslash
expressions in the string so i cannot
write this with an f string i have to
use the dot format
the rule here
doesn't really give you a good sense of
why f string versus that format
the rule here doesn't really give you a
broader sense of anything but a
restriction that came up when they were
deciding how to design this feature in a
corner case where when they wanted to
parse parse f strings and they wanted to
make it possible for additional tooling
to be able to syntax highlight f strings
they just couldn't figure out how to get
the backslashes to work in a consistent
fashion
easily and cleanly and as a consequence
they just said
we're going to rule against this we're
going to forbid f backslashes and f
strings
that
that rules exist doesn't necessarily
mean that rules are intuitive or drive
conceptual understanding doesn't mean
they make sense but
the rules that we're going to talk about
the indexing rules despite them having
as incomprehensible errors as the syntax
error f string expression part cannot
include a backslash why not
well the broadcasting rules and the
index alignment rules make a lot of
sense and why they are the way they are
is
something that can help you drive better
conceptual intuitive understanding of a
tool like pandas
because here
if we focus on this role these are one
of the right rules to focus on we can
see how everything fits together
here are the rules of index alignment
what you do
sorry the rules of broadcasting
is
you take
the dimensionality of the structures
you're looking at and you align them and
you right align them so i'm going to
take each one of these things that i
tried i'm going to rightline them and
then you try and match them up and when
you try and match them up you're either
looking for an exact match so four
against four
or
for there to be something missing you're
doing like a zip that's going in reverse
so you stop at the short of the two or a
one
here two by three by four against two
these don't match four doesn't match
with two two by three by four against
two by three doesn't match two by three
by four against three by four that
matches the four against the four the
three against three so it's just going
to do that operation
taking that wise and apply it to this
level here
twice for that wise of two that i did
the new axis that new axis or the
indexing with none same thing it's just
about nesting this a little bit deeper
to add one more layer to this and have
that layer be just one element because
a two by two structure is the exact same
thing as a two by two by one by one by
one by one by one structure well this
new axis is just my way to obey the
broadcasting rules to make these things
line up in broadcasting you write a line
then just match up the shape you match
up these dimensions looking either for
an exact match or for one of the two to
be equal to one and if one of the two is
equal to one then you just broadcast
against that and so
that's how broadcasting works and
you can even double check this work here
and and why it's all right alignments of
a left alignment makes sense in terms of
what we know about pen about numpy numpy
is a raw view of an interpretive view of
raw memory
and
numpy has some shape and if you look at
the shape of this thing two by three by
four and you look at the strides of this
thing you might say well the shape is
how we interpret this data as a cube or
a rectangular prism with two layers and
three rows and four columns each
the strides is how we move between the
values to go from layer to layer we skip
96 bytes to go from row to row we skip
32 bytes to go from column to column we
skip 8 bytes because it's n64 data of
course 8 bytes what you can see from the
strides is that the
outermost
of these the rightmost of these axes is
the most tightly packed
these are the values that are most
contiguous in memory these individual
column values are most contiguous in
memory
well that's probably why you would
choose to write a lining you want to
start from the things that are most
contiguous to memory to the things that
are least contiguous memory so you're
not jumping around memory too much and
when you perform operations on this
numpy and d array and you think about
you know what an indexing does you can
understand what this indexing does in
terms of strides when you ask where x
equals zero well why the indexing works
from the outermost to the innermost is
you're
you're drilling down into the data but
you always want to get the thing that's
as contiguous as possible because that's
going to be as fast as possible and so
that's why the broadcasting works from
the right-hand side but the indexing
works from the left-hand side and you
can see this whenever you do indexing
every time you're doing an indexing
you're just saying oh give me a little
bit of that view of that underlying
memory and just give me this particular
contiguous block and even if you're
doing the indexing and saying getting
just a particular column or something
you can see that still works you just
end up skipping over more values well
when i take my ys and i can see my
striding you can think that this y that
has had a new axis applied to it twice
over
is something which just has
zero in terms of the number of values
you skip
because it turns out that you can
increase the dimensionality of a numpy
and d array paying almost no cost by
just telling it oh you have one more
dimension you have one more axis
associated with it and that axis just
contains one value and the strides for
that it's just zero you don't skip it
around at all
you can even debug your broadcasting
issues using broadcast two from them but
you can see if i take zs and i try and
figure out how it would be turned into
something that's compatible with x's you
can see oh it would turn into something
that has
zero starting at the beginning it's just
going to repeat that thing as many times
as it needs to repeat it on this
particular axis it all kind of makes
sense and so without further ado let us
talk about the rules of index alignment
because it turns out they're all about
just matching things up
now the rules have a couple of small
parts to them but let's talk about the
simplest case where there are no
duplicate values in your index
and so here i have two pandas series and
the two series are indexed a b c d and a
b c d no duplicate values everything
matches up and the indexes know that
they're sorted they know they're
monotonic and they know they don't
contain duplicates when you add s1 plus
to s2 it just matches things up exactly
it takes the value at a and the value at
a and adds that the value of b in the
value b and adds that the value of c in
the value would see an ad set didn't i
tell you that the
collections.counter
is a first order approximation to a
pandas series well it is i mean this is
just adding up the corresponding keys to
get the value with a little bit simpler
of a syntax
if it's the case that these things do
not line up directly then it'll try and
do the lineup as much as it possibly can
but it's going to figure out that oh one
of these slides doesn't have a the other
side doesn't have e whereas the
collections.counter will fill in with
the zero numpy will fill in sorry pandas
will fill in with the nan and so that's
why you have those nands surrounding
this
it is the case that if you wanted to
look at the indexing mechanism yourself
you could play with the index you could
say hey index tell me if i'm going to do
an operation with you against this other
index what would happen you can see oh
if these are dissimilar indices it's
going to add up the first value the
second value and the third value and
it's going to fill in the blank for the
other one and presumably as part of this
operation what we're going to do is
we're going to do this get indexer on
both sides and union the two and that's
what the result is going to be so the
result will be the consequences of this
lookup of these values and this lookup
these values merge together now if we
look at these indi
indexers we can even see that the
indexers have some additional behavior
we can backfill the indexers so if we
have bcde and abcd we can backfill so we
can say oh if you're missing something
just pick the values before that we can
forward fill something so we can say oh
if you're bcde and cdef well just if
you're missing values and this is
monotonic just fill it going forwards
and we can even look for the nearest
value so the indices don't match exactly
you can just find the nearest value and
when you think about that and the get
indexer you can see oh this is a
mechanism and that mechanism has rules
associated with it for how it matches
these things up and the different types
of indices may have more sophisticated
mechanisms than just an exact match
index alignment is about matching things
up but it's not necessarily about an
exact match it's about how the index
considers the match to be exact whether
it considers one of these methods to be
the most appropriate method and nearest
match this is why you can put actual
date time values
in a pandas index a datetime index and
then look it up with a string well the
index knows how to convert the string
into a datetime value and then perform
that matching unfortunately these
different indexing
mechanisms these indexing modalities are
not available on most of the operations
you could perform on a panda's series
directly you can see if you do an s1.add
you can only really specify the level
and the fill value the axis you can't
specify how to do the indexing how to do
a forward fill or backfill but those are
operations that are available
on the series itself so you first
transform the series into shape and then
you let the add be a very simple thing
or
what you do
is you do index operations and then once
you have the index operations you apply
them to the data i often find that a lot
of the very complex pandas code that i
write does quite a bit of work to first
figure out what values i want to merge
or what values i want to operate they do
index operations and then finally once i
figured out how to whittle down to the
data that i care about then i go to the
raw data and i pull it out and i perform
some operation on it
the collections.counter is a first order
approximation to a panda series and so
you can see all of these behaviors in
play you know if i have two series and
i'm and i match them up or two two
series and i add them together it's just
like a collections.counter matching them
up
if there are duplicates in the index
what would the reasonable way to match
up values b
if one of these indices had two a's in
it and the other one didn't how would we
match them up well probably what we'd do
is we'd match
each a in the first one against each a
in the second we do a cartesian product
here if we look at these indices we can
see one side
has duplicates and the other side does
not and so how do you match things up
there's duplicates on one side well you
match one of the things on one side to
every one of the things on the other
side that's why there were more rows in
that previous example because it was
doing the cartesian product of the
places where there were duplicates and
because the index knows it has
duplicates it'll use that as part of
this operation you can see a 3 a
negative 3 well that's because you match
the a7 and the first one against the a
negative 4 and the a negative 10.
index alignment also performs this
cartesian product
and if it's the case that there are
duplicates on both sides
well then you're just going to do the
cartesian product of every place you see
duplicates if there's two a's on one
side and two a's the other side then
you're going to get four values in the
result for that a because you're going
to match every one of one against every
one of the other and that's the
reasonable way to match thing up because
if you collected some data and you said
i collected this data labeled a
and i collected two measurements for
label a on one side of the data set and
i collected two labeled measurements a
and others on the other data set
i probably want to pair them up in all
the different possible combinations um
and if i didn't want to do that i
probably would have used unique labels
your choice of whether these labels are
unique or not is you telling pandas
consider these to be the same conceptual
entity and so please perform the
cartesian product
it's not that this is a
obscure thing that pandas has done to
confuse you it's that you've asked
pandas to do the wrong thing by telling
panda something that's not quite correct
about the metadata related to your data
remember and it is critical to
understand this the pandas index is not
like a primary key it is not guaranteed
to be unique it is not guaranteed to be
sorted it is just some mechanism for
looking up the data dead stop is just a
mechanism and in fact non-unique
non-sorted indices come up all the time
let me show you an example of a
non-unique index here we have a date
here we have a series and that series is
on a
time index it's on a daytime index
and you can see i have captured these on
different
dis uniform
measurements down to the second from the
first of the month to the 22nd of the
month
now for my purposes i might want to
resample this so i might want to
resample this in terms of every minute
and so here you can see i have every
minute and everything's been rounded
nicely and i have one row corresponding
to every minute and there's a bunch of
nands here because i don't have enough
measurements for every single minute
there's just too many mission
measurements this is not too different
from the idea of grouping these values
by
those times rounded to the minute and
then performing the mean as well and if
we were curious about what the
difference between this resample and
this group i might be we could do a
little bit of index mathematics a little
bit of index manipulation to figure out
what that would be we could take the
index we could take the first operation
and that we've resampled on one minute
intervals and we could take
every value and put them into a set but
not the values themselves maybe the
index
contents and put them into a set and so
here you can see for this resampling
that is the original data sample that
got core that
at that particular index value at two
seconds past the minute that got
bucketed into
51 minutes past the hour
and i could do the same thing
on my group by
and you can see where they don't match
up is going to be the cases where this
dot group by with the rounded time
series is going to be different than the
resample and in fact i could take these
two results and i could put them into a
data frame
and here you can see
this data frame is a collection of like
indexed one-dimensional series so this
data frame contains
all of the measurements from the
original data set that correspond to 51
minutes past the hour for the resample
case and for the group by case and so
you can see for that resample in that
group by case the actual
value should be the same because i'm
performing the mean on the same values
but anywhere where these differ it's
going to be different in the resample
case you can see the resample is giving
me entries for every uniform minute
whereas the group by is giving me no
values if i didn't have anything to
measure so the group by says nan here
and doesn't have any values in the
result whereas the resample just have an
m value because there weren't any values
to perform a mean on
if i take this result
and
i look for all the places where they are
in common
you can see these are all the places
where the group by and the resample
matched up in terms of the signals that
they
were going to compute as part of the
mean if i take that and i capture the
index of this result all by itself
then
i can
index this thing
where
where it's true and i can see these are
all the samples where things matched up
so these are all the places in the
result where things matched up i can
take that and i compute what the same
indices are
i can look up the the resample in the
group i where the same index are and
then see if they're all matching up
exactly as i said anywhere where they
grouped on the same values anywhere
where they join the same number of
values together in that mean
they should be the exact same value so
that gives me the common index if i want
the different index i can do another
index operation i can take the original
indices of everything they both have
subtract out everywhere where they're
different
and
i can see all the places where they
differ
and what you can see here is index
mathematics come up pretty commonly it's
the case that any time you have a very
large data set you're working with
another data set and you've captured
this metadata it's not uncommon for you
to do these index operations say okay
take this data and then subset it and
substance subset it and if you're not
using the index you're probably doing
this on the raw data so you're making
lots of copies of the raw data which may
have many many many columns and so that
could be a very expensive copy
and it's probably many lines of code
with lots of for loops that nobody can
make ads or tales of but here what i'm
saying is
take these two structures figure out
what samples were included in each
bucket find all the buckets where
they're the same and then compute all
the places where you use the same bucket
compute all the places where you use a
different bucket and then actually go up
and look in the original data to find
what the corresponding calculation was
for those buckets and verify that the
group buy and the resample
are sometimes the same in some places
and sometimes different in the other
places but the only difference there is
how they bucketed how they performed
this windowing operation
if you think beyond the panda series
because we often don't use a panda
series directly if we're not that
familiar with pandas we'll often just
use a data frame all the time but it
turns out the panda series is a very
useful tool all by itself well here is
an example of a pandas data frame and a
pandas data frame that you may have
worked with before it has dates it has
dickers it has prices it has volumes and
we can do operations like do a dot lock
give me the element
at
the label 0
and
the ticker column
you can do a dot i lock give me the
element at
position 0 and column 0. so i guess that
would be the date
give me the element
at
label zero
oh
maybe that's why when i had the series
with the square bracket indexing
sometimes there's some ambiguity because
when you look at something like a data
frame and you perform an operation on
that data frame you're going to get a
row or a column and if that's a single
row in a single column it's going to be
a pandas series and if it's a panda
series you're going to want to do a
another lookup on that maybe a square
bracket lookup and what are you most
likely to do you're most likely to have
string named columns
and so you're most likely to want to
operate on the labeling
for the subsequent operations that you
perform once you do the lookup in the
data frame to reduce that to a series
and you want to do an operation on the
series
and if you look at these dot lock and
dot ilock operations you can see there's
quite a few of these you can see this
gave us a series object so that's why it
had this implicit behavior it's just
trying to guess what's most common
because nobody really wants to do dot
lock dot lock like this even though
that's less ambiguous and you can see
the dot lock even has the ability to to
have two parameters you can say give me
everything
for
the ticker column
and for every particular row
now let me remind you pandas is very
one-dimensional the main reason to use
it is the index
and it's very one-dimensional
it only stores one dimensional data a
panda series is a one dimensional data
set that has one index
a data frame is doubly indexed what a
pandas data frame is you have collected
multiple measurements those measurements
are collected with the same metadata the
same indexing mechanism
you want to store them together and line
them up
and as part of storing them together and
lining them up you also want to refer to
those measurements by another index a
data frame is a doubly indexed structure
where it contains like indexed
one-dimensional data pandas is only
one-dimensional data yes the pandas
documentation calls it two-dimensional
data because there are two coordinates
for a dot lock or a dot i lock for
accessing something
but if we try and compare a pandas data
frame like the data frame here
to our x-ray data and we said the x-ray
data was clearly two-dimensional data
this is not really two-dimensional data
because
i can only look down the rows or down
the columns to perform a meaningful
operation i cannot look down the
diagonals
yes i can access this data via two
coordinates but this data is not
homogeneous
if i perform an arbitrary rotation of
this data the data fundamentally changes
what it means
whereas with an image it doesn't really
fundamentally change what it means it
just means you're tilting your head a
little bit sideways
this is actually four data sets that
i've collected
the date the ticker the price and the
volume
and
i've collected this data with the same
indexing and in fact date and ticker
that's not
data
that's not something that i collected
that's a labeling what i really should
do with this data set is i should have
indexed it on the date and the ticker
it's two data sets i've collected one
price one volume and i've collected them
with the same date and ticker and i want
to line them up and i want to perform
operations making use
of those being lined up
operations not only on this data frame
itself but operations combining this
data frame with others
this is what a pandas data frame is all
about and this is what pandas is all
about indexed one-dimensional data
whether it is
one indexed one-dimensional data set a
panda series or a collection of like
index one-dimensional data a data frame
that's what pandas is all about let us
take a look here i have a data frame and
you can see this data frame
if i access
one of these
rows using dot lock it gives me a row it
gives me this row as a pandas series if
i access one column of this it gives me
a column of this if i look at what that
column is it's a series a panda series
is not a row or a column of a pandas
data frame a panda series is just a one
dimensional data set
when you go into a pandas data frame and
you ask for a subset of that panda's
data frame and that subset of that
panasonic frame happens to be
one-dimensional you get a series back
that's the relationship between a panda
series and a pandas data frame one is
for collections of like
one index of like-indexed
one-dimensional data and the other one
is just one
one like indexed or one
indexed one-dimensional data and for the
data frame if you're collecting these
together you put one more index to just
be able to refer to what those
individual items are let me show you
something that happens quite often in
pandas
here
if i look up
the element at location 0 the location 2
because i'm using dot lock this is going
to be index aware so if i change what
the indexing is it is going to change
what the result is
a dot lock operation is not guaranteed
to give you a series or a data frame
unless you are absolutely certain what
the contents of that index is because if
there are repeated values in that
index.lock
is going to give you two rows the two
rows where this data is set to
is set to zero and it gives you a data
frame
whereas if you ask for entry two there's
only one entry there's no duplicates for
two it only gives you one the dot lock
operation gives you anything
give you a data frame give you a series
i guess those are the two options but i
can give you either one of those two
options and you need to understand what
the indexing is in order to make that
work where dot ilock is helpful and
word.ilock is a very useful tool even if
you often think about your data in terms
of
this metadata this indexing is the eye
lock is unambiguous it always represents
the physical position so i lock of 0
always means physical position 0 and
there can't be two physical positions
zero that is unique the dot i lock can
be thought of as an indexing with a
range index a unique range index
starting from zero up to the size of the
structure that's what i like really is
now when you do these operations like
you ask a pandas data frame for
one column or one row one of the things
you can see
is that the indexing of this will
correspond to the corresponding indexing
on their side so in other words if the
original data frame was index 0 1 1 on
the columns and 0 0 1 1 2 on the rows
and i ask for row 0 the indexing of the
result is going to take the column
indexing this is why it's doubly indexed
so when you look at a particular slice
down a row or down a column you know how
to index the result of that using
the column index if you looked at a row
or using the row index if you looked at
a column and you can see the name of
this panda series is set to the value
of
the index that you operated on to get
this particular data set so if i look
for entry two
the name here will be set to two and the
index will be set to whatever the
corresponding columns were for that and
you'll see this irrespective whether you
look at a column or a row
and so now it kind of makes sense why it
is that we have this implicit behavior
this implicit behavior on the panda
series with the square bracket all by
itself is basically trying to guess what
it thinks you're trying to do when you
do these chained operations do you
really want to look at the column names
do you really want to look at the row
names and
depending on the circumstances
you may want one or the other and
sometimes this works sometimes it
doesn't but of course you can always
just.i lock or dot lock your way into
explicitness
the setting with copy warning actually
makes sense
consider this
if you have a pandas data frame
and you ask that pandas data frame for
one row because this is not
two-dimensional data but multiple data
sets that are like indexed there is no
guarantee that those columns contain the
same type of data
meaning
the result that you get out of this
retrieval of one row
is going to be a pandas series
with potentially an object d type
because here this row contained a string
a float and an end
how do i store that contiguously will i
have to use the object d-type i can't
store these in 64's because what do i do
with the flow what i do with the string
if you're doing that and the panda
series is built on top of say a numpy
and d array the numpy and area wants
these to be contiguous
then this lookup is going to make a copy
it's going to copy
this series or it's going to create a
series backed by some new data and that
new data is going to be the python
pi object pointer values the reference
values for these underlying entities in
memory
uh and it may even make a copy to bring
these back into the boxed universe
depending on depending on what needs to
be done here but whatever the case is
here a copy is being made you looked up
a
a row and it had to make a copy because
this row contained non-homogeneous data
and had to do something in order to
represent this and because it had to do
that and because i had to make a copy
if you try and do a setting on that copy
that setting might fail
because that setting is going to change
the copy not change the original data
and the addition of that additional
column in the previous example that
changed this from everything working to
everything
you know failing with that
can't set or setting with copy warning
was because
in one of those cases i had only integer
data
because i only had integer data the
series didn't have to make a copy
because i could just get a series with
integers in them here because this is
homo heterogeneous data i have to make a
copy and this is why that wording
happens and so the solution to this is
pretty clear don't make a copy and
that's why that dot ilock happens to
have the ability to take two different
dimensions two different coordinates
here this is to allow you to say give me
the value at zero
on the
[Music]
positions for the rows and c on the
position for the column away that
doesn't work
give me the value at
0 on the label for the rows
and c on the labels
for
the columns
okay that worked
or
give me
the element at zero on the positions for
the rows
and
at the position for wherever the c
occurred in the columns using get lock
you can see direct use of the index here
or vice versa unfortunately this dot
lock and dot getlock
does.ilockon.lock operator do not allow
you to mix and match whether you use
labeled or positional indexing which is
oftentimes why people do the the
multi-stage indexing
but
in these cases what you might need to do
is you might need to actually use the
index directly in order to figure out
where that element is so you can
consistently use that lock or dot iloc
with just positions or just labels
so if we think about a panda's data
frame and we think about what this thing
really is a panda's data frame is
typified by
the block manager data that it contains
the actual data in this thing in this
case a couple of integers a couple of
floating point values and a couple of
string values
that block manager is a topic for
another day it is very complex how it
works and it can be very opaque in terms
of its operation
closer to the surface however we have
the index which is our way to refer to
the rows of this structure
and the columns which is another way to
refer to the rows of the structure and
these are both indices sometimes people
call the index the row index or the
major axis sometimes people call the
columns the column index or the minor
axis columns index can be somewhat
misleading in part because they're both
index objects they're both mechanisms by
which we can refer to the underlying
data
and
everything just kind of makes sense when
you see
how the index works and so let's wrap up
our discussion of the rules of index
alignment by talking about what the
rules of the index line are on the
structure that we commonly use the data
frame
if we happen to have
two pandas data frames and they both
look like this
and these are doubly indexed collections
of like indexed one-dimensional data
what we can think is if we perform an
operation on these together it's going
to match things up on both the rows and
the columns index it's going to match up
from the first to the fifth of the year
and from the second to the sixth of the
year on that row index so i'll get nands
at the top and nan's at the bottom
because i'm missing one one row for one
of these and missing one row for the
other and since the columns are the same
it's just going to match those columns
up by name
and that's exactly what i expect
if there is an extra column in one
then we get all nand values because it's
going to match things up on both of
these indices
what are the rules for combining a
series with a data frame
well when you have a pandas data frame
that looks like this
and you have a panda series that looks
like this
it's going to match the columns of the
data frame against the rows of the
series and notice even though it should
make sense to you oh yeah you're just
going to take that series you're just
going to take that 0 1 8 and just
multiply them across that's not actually
what happens when i perform this it
gives me a weird result with a bunch of
nands because it took the
row index of that series
and it tried to match against the
columns and because the row index of
series in the column didn't match up i
just get a bunch of data all nands and
it doesn't matter the order in which i
perform this operation it always matches
the rows of the
series against the columns of the index
and i can't transpose my way out of this
by the way because a pandas series
is not something that could be
transposed it's not a column vector or
row vector it's just a one-dimensional
data set so it has no notion of what its
orientation is the transposition of a
panda series is just the series itself
and so there is no way for me to
transpose my way around this but this
actually makes sense why this rule is in
place if you think about how we actually
use pandas series and we think about the
operations we actually perform
and so
if we take a look at these two
structures
here i have a series that matches the
column indexing of the data frame
then i can add these together
and i can immediately see how this is
useful if i go back to my real ish world
data
going back to my real world data here is
my data frame containing dates tickers
prices and values i've already set the
index of the date and the ticker
i have some factors
and this is indexed by the ticker so for
each one of these stickers i have some
multiplicative factor that i want to
take this original data
and i want to multiply it through by if
you think about it that multiplicative
factor is unlikely to affect both the
price and the volume
if you think this is maybe even an added
factor it makes even more sense why it's
unlikely to affect both the price can't
be negative but the volume can the
volume is integer data and the price is
floating point data so it's unlikely for
that factor to apply to both of these
it's more likely
for this factor to apply to just one of
these columns and so what i'm likely to
do is i'm likely to take the data frame
pull out the one column that i want
which gives me a pandas series and do a
series based alignment here that makes
sense
or
what i'm likely to do is take two data
frames that have the factors for the
prices and the factors for the for the
volumes and apply those data frame by
data frame matching up the columns on
one column against the other the rows on
one the rows against the other
if i mismatch them then what it's
thinking is what i want to do is i want
to match up the columns i want to do
something to all the prices and
something to all the factors
moving down that data frame because most
of the operations that you can see are
performed on a panda series or a panda's
data frame tend to be performed down the
data frame down the series down the rows
of this structure
now you can see here this is a
multi-index structure so i can do things
like index slice this data frame to get
all the places where i'm looking at
ticker ar and q
and this index aligned operation is
aware of that so even though
i have
all of these prices and this is indexed
by this multi-index of the date and the
ticker and i have this factor
that only includes the ticker
pandas is smart enough to figure out
match each one of those against every
one of those dates
think about how much pure python code
how much looping code it would take for
you to make that work in the same
fashion
so what is this multi-index and what are
the alignment rules well the alignment
rules are pretty straightforward the
exact same alignment rules that you see
on the series in the data frame it's
just that pandas is able to use the name
of the index levels in order to figure
out how these things match up and this
is why you sometimes get these errors
around oh this is misnamed this is why
you can see i always set the name of my
series i said the name of my indices
that's what pandas is using that's the
metadata that pandas uses to figure out
how to do the matching
let me show you a series with a
multi-index here's a series with a bunch
of symbols and a bunch of quarters that
i've collected this data from if i look
at this i can see this is clearly a
multi-index
if i do a lock operation i can see this
is hierarchical so i can look at
everything for q1
or i can drill down and i look at
everything for q1 and abc you can see if
i did this
with another index so if this is our
data frame and i had another
coordinate here representing the column
that i'm looking for is this
one-dimensional is this two-dimensional
is this like nested one-dimensional you
can see why the multi-index definitely
makes this not really our sense of
one-dimensional because there's two
coordinates that are used for one and
one coordinate used for the other but
they're not splattered this is
nonsensical because this would be a
three-dimensional data set
panda's data frame isn't really
two-dimensional it's actually like index
dimensional data but
here you can see
i can drill down and i can even use
index slice to do really smart cross
sections like give me the abc and the
xyz for q1 2021 and because it's a very
smart index i can even give it an actual
date like the 15th of march forward and
it figures out which quarters are going
to be affected and then does a slice on
those to give me the corresponding
tickers and the index alignment here is
just smart and it figures out what
layers match up to what layers and does
the index line on those layers
note
multi-index is a topic for another day
and it is a very big topic
people are often afraid of the
multi-index especially if they don't
like using the index itself because it
has these weird hierarchical behaviors
but the multi-index is not the only
hierarchical index because
it turns out because that index is just
a mechanism hierarchical indices pop up
all the time a date time index is
hierarchical if you ask for just the
year the year i'll give you all the rows
for that year
just like if you had asked the
multi-index for just one layer of that
index and there's a drill down that's
possible with the date time index just
like the drill down that's possible with
a multi-index it's just that the syntax
for it is very slightly different
because where the different layers are
being separated
is once this date time is parsed
by the date time index or in terms of
what input that i give to the
multi-index but largely these are if you
think about it a daytime index is
actually a multi-index
where each level
is each fidelity of time measurement
that you have year month day and so
forth as deep as you happen to have
fidelity and so this is actually a
multi-index with three levels or
equivalent to conceptually equivalent to
a multi-index with three levels year
month and day it's just storing that as
one particular index without some of the
syntax of the multi-index
and so
if we take all of this
and we try and figure out
indices are they useful
very
indices do we need to understand how
they work and do we need to use them
ourselves yes
indices and index alignment if we think
about hidden indexes in indices and
index alignment and think about how they
work can we become a pandas expert yes
because it turns out that almost
everything that you can do on a panda
series or a panda's data frame can be
determined or or discussed or defined in
terms of operations on that index for
example here is a series it is indexed
on individual days i can group it by
month and i can do a mean but you can
see i get an index that's the month
number that's not probably what i want
what i can do is i can have the group by
i can operate on my linux and turn this
into period and do that group by and
then with this result i can i have a
nicer index so i can look up exact dates
and have those exact dates translate to
the months and have everything work
nicely this is way easier than just
doing a group by index month and then
i'm basically back to something akin to
my range index because i have to figure
out how to map
actual dates two months whereas i could
have let the index do this myself
all the different operations that i can
do in the group by make sense in terms
of the index
if i have a structure
and i want to group it by something
and i want the result
to reflect indexing based on the groups
i want whatever my groups to become the
new index that is dot ack what dot ag is
about is taking the groups and
collapsing to one scalar value so you
can produce as the end result something
that is indexed on each of the groups
and there's one value for each of those
which is whatever whatever user defined
function you've provided so here you can
see ag with the skew or ag with the
kurtosis
transform
is about preserving the original
indexing so what transform is about is
saying take some structure with some
indexing
perform some transformation on it but
keep what the original indexing look
like and so the udf that's passed the
transform
should preserve that indexing so i can't
use kurtosis or skew because those are
reductions those will collapse but i
could use something like z score and you
can see here the z score did what i
wanted
apply is about saying you know what
i don't want either of those i want a
brand new indexing apply is about doing
any operation that can perform a that
can result in any new index and then
concatenating these back into a panda's
data frame later and so if i wanted to
group these by their month and then i
wanted to take all the positive values
and find the cumulative sum
well that's going to drop rows so the
resulting index is neither going to be
just the groups nor is it going to be
the
original
index it's going to have the original
index of pieces missing i have to use
apply and when you look at the result of
apply you can see it tacks the indexing
that was created by the udf here
onto
the indexing that is implied by the
grouping because you kind of want to
know oh these were the dates that i
grouped together to form this and this
is main case where you might want to
drop one of these levels you might want
to do a little bit of reset index just
to throw away part that you do or do not
care about but that's what apply is all
about there is one more additional
dimension to this which is that
aggregate and transform work on a series
basis and apply works on a data frame
basis but unfortunately we're not here
to talk about rolling functions we're
here to talk about the index and so
we'll have to leave that for a future
presentation
if we look at about
80 percent of the pandas data frame api
almost all of these operations can be
thought of in terms of something related
to the index
here
is our data frame
with our time series data and i'm going
to talk about as much of the pandas api
as i can fit there's some parts of the
pandas api i won't talk about i won't
talk about things like endem and shape
the number of dimensions and the shape
of this thing the number of dimensions
of a panda's data frame is always two
the number of dimensions of a panda
series is always one the shape is always
the number of rows and two or the number
of rows or the number of entries and one
not particularly interesting i'm not
going to talk about things like the
metadata like the flags and the
attributes not that interesting i'm not
going to pluck the index the columns and
the axes the axes that's just the index
and the columns in a tuple not that
interesting i want to talk about
operations like stack and unstack
here's what unstack is
unstack is taking a layer of a
multi-index and pivoting it up into a
layer of the column so you can see you
take the innermost layer of the
multi-index on the rows and you pivot up
to be the
innermost layer of the multi-index on
the columns
why you might do this is because if you
were to do matplotlib plotting directly
from pandas each column usually produces
an independent graph and so sometimes
here you might want to have one line for
each ticker for each price in each
volume
is this useful from an analytical
perspective maybe maybe not but
definitely from a plotting perspective
unstack and then you plot this and you
get one of these per
particular stack is just the opposite
operation it's just taking
one layer of that column index and
pivoting it down into one layer the
outermost layer of or
the the innermost layer i should say of
this row index so there you go is this
useful in this particular case probably
not because most operations you perform
on a pandas data frame are down the rows
and
i don't know what operation you could
perform on prices and volumes together
that's that's not clear to me and so
here that's probably not particularly
useful but you can think as duals there
may be a case where you want to take
something and stack it or unstack it in
general these are useful operations
things like melt and pivot if you look
at a different data frame a data frame
that looks like this
this data frame is something that maybe
might have been read from an excel file
because you can see you can imagine how
somebody put this in excel each row
corresponded to one ticker and they have
some sectors associated with them and
they have the dates where they captured
some measurement and when you look at
that you say okay that kind of makes
sense well what i want to do is i want
to operate on this in a consistent
fashion i actually want to take part
of those of that column index and i want
to take that and pull it down into the
data that's what melt is all about
melt is all about saying
take
part of my columns namely everything but
the sector column and move it down into
my data and so here you can see the
column labels are this variable column
and the corresponding values of this
value column and it's a very bizarre set
of names because you can see there's
like var name and you can name what
these columns are
if you don't ignore the index you
preserve the original indexing and if
you set the id vars you actually
duplicate any variables that are
supposed to be identity
identifier variables this is actually
two data sets that has been stored in
the same structure but here you can see
oh okay each date each sector each value
and here probably what i want to do is i
want to set the index
here
into this thing and sort the index so
now i have each ticker each date in the
index and i probably even want to swap
the levels of these so it's date ticker
and the
and then the sector and then that and i
probably want to sort the index on this
so here's what my result looks like
now
if we think about melt in that fashion
pivot is kind of a dual of melt and when
you think about something like pivot
again you can think about this in terms
of operations performed on the index
the pivot is just about doing some sort
of group by and then an unstack so if i
took these values and i wanted to group
them by the month in which these values
occurred for the original data frame
i want to group these by the month in
which the values occurred and then i
wanted to take the sum of these values
for the month and then i wanted to
unstack this
here you can see i'm doing some sort of
pivoting operation to take whatever is
in
the
outermost layer of the row index and
move it up into the
or the innermost layer of the row index
move it up to the innermost layer of the
column index well
a group by unstack is basically a pivot
table operation
a pivot table operation is just you
explicitly saying what do i want the
index to look like
what do i want the column index to look
like and how do i want to compute what
the cell values are and so here i'm
going to pivot this by saying oh i want
as my index to be the dates by month i
want us the columns to be whatever was
in that original
index layer or column called ticker and
i want the aggregation function to be
the sum of everything that that managed
to match up that's all pivot tables just
an operation where you set what the
columns are when we set the indexes sort
index obviously sort by the index
you can sort by the index on either axis
this is just going to alphabetize what
your
this is just going to alphabetize either
in
ascending or descending order what your
columns are
because it's just going to sort on that
column index and this column and it's
just strings
why does sort index use ascending equals
true and false instead of reverse like
the sorted function in python i don't
know i mean there's cases where the
pandas api
diverges from what we might expect this
is probably influenced by some some
non-python tool
i can sort by values okay that's pretty
obvious reset index what reset index
does is it takes a layer of the index
and it pops it into the data
is that useful well in some cases you do
want to throw away the index or in some
cases you may have preserved the index
as a metadata deep into an operation and
at that layer you know that index only
contains one value and so it's no longer
valuable to have that index anymore as
part of some sort of subsetting you have
all of just the same ticker maybe you
did a group by and you're doing some
sort of nested group by pop off the
index you don't need to you don't need
to be you know percolated back up if you
did like a group by apply
you can drop this as well
and set index is basically the dual of
resetting says take a column take the
data and move it into the index all of
these operations are just moving things
around either from the column index the
row index from the data to the to the
index from the index to the data
here you can say
set the index and append it i'll just
set it as an extra level
drop level that's just about dropping
one level of the index take off the part
of the index
that has ticker in it
and drop it by name and that's why
naming these makes sense
re-index just says take the data set
and
don't change what's in the index change
what the data is
based off a new index look up new things
reindex says here you have your data
with your indexing give me a new
structure and look up all the values
using this index to look them up so
reindex here is just saying oh you know
give me all the values from the 1st of
february
every 14 days and for 4 periods so that
should be up until about mid march
that's all reindexes
set axis very strangely name but set
access is about
setting the values of the index
given some map or some values itself
sorry using given the actual values
itself so set index taking the columns
and then uppercasing them or title
casing them and setting this acts as a
column this is just setting the values
of the index
just
mutating the index the index what the
index contains presuming that the index
is backed by some data what this would
do for a non-data backed index might be
ambiguous i'm not sure what this will
end up calling i think this will
actually end up trying to do
set item operations on the index and so
how the index is going to intermediate
that and figure out what to do is up to
the index mechanics itself and so this
is where the index api can be a little
bit large and this is a case where you
know
maybe this this has increased the size
of the api for the index
you know what rename does
all it does
is it renames
all it does is it
is it
renames the values of sorry
it sets the values of one of the two
indices the column index or the row
index using a mapper it's basically set
index but not using the data using a
mapper instead so here you can see
instead of actually performing the
computation to
title case all these i can just give it
a function to title case all of these
myself
and so what rename could be used for is
if i didn't want to do this on the
columns i want to do this on the rows
maybe i want to do a uniform
transformation to part of this index i
want to take that date and i want to
push it forward or push it back one day
i could do a rename on this and you can
see this pulled everything back one day
just go into every one of those values
and then performed an operation on them
swap level just swaps the level of the
index
reorder levels just re-orders level of
given some ordering rename axis
just renames what the axis is called not
the contents of that axis but what that
access is called because if you look at
the dot columns
this dot columns is an index that has a
name field as you do stack and unstack
operations that name field is going to
be used to figure out what to name
things when you pull something from a
layer of the column index into the row
index
and we did that with our previous stack
operation you can see
it was missing it was a blank there
because it wasn't named originally so
rename x is about naming these and it's
valuable to name these so that when you
do multi-indexed index alignment pandas
knows how to match things up that's why
that rename access came up before pandas
didn't know how to match things up so
you named the layers of that multi-index
in the previous example and so panda
said oh now i know what matches up index
alignment and you're off to the races
and you see that when you stack this
thing and you look at the index you can
see oh this layer of the index didn't
have a name because i hadn't named it
that's all it is all about
swap access
is just about
transposing this i don't really
understand why swap acts exists in
addition to transpose sometimes the
pandas api
isn't always clear there may be some use
case for swap access that's not the same
as
transpose squeeze is just about taking
something that possibly could be a
series but it's currently a data frame
and dropping it to a series it doesn't
force something into a series and so
here you can see it didn't do anything
to my data frame but if my data frame
happened to be just one column
squeeze said you know what i'm just
going to make this a series and notice
what happened to the name the name was
whatever the name of the original column
was
and so this is where squeeze comes up
and you can squeeze on either axis if
you want you can squeeze on the index or
the squeeze on the columns
explode
is the opposite
explode is
not quite the opposite explode is the
idea that one of the values in your data
might be some sort of nested information
like say a list as a consequence of how
you read this in maybe it's like a csv
file where each csv entry had some sub
entries explode just says explode notice
it explodes it down
the
the rows and notice how it preserves the
indexing see duplicate
duplicated values in an index come all
the time you can see the seven was
attached to the three the three was
attached to zero it's just exploding
something nested into additional rows
common operations like at and i at and
lock and
i lock just about accessing things what
you can think is if you do an i at
and for that i ad we're missing a pair
of parentheses here
you try and access
oh and this should be square brackets
here if you do an i at you can access a
single value
or an at you can access a single value
you can either access a single value by
its label or an accessible value by its
position
very similar to dot lock and i lock the
one tiny difference between these is
these will always give you the scalar
values whereas a dot lock is going to
give you potentially a series a data
frame it will give you a panda structure
back whereas the eye lock may give you
just a single value
other operations dot head
just use it's basically just like an i
lock giving me the first three entries
or give me the first n entries a tail
it's just like an eye lock giving me the
last range it's just an index not aware
operation sample is just like an eye
locks giving me some random choice of
values
all of the binary operators like dot add
index aligned they take the index from
one the index from another and they add
them up and here i'm adding this to
itself and so obviously it'll be indexed
lined already sub is the same subtract
is just because people don't want to
write subtract and so they write sub
instead but some people really want to
be very clear that this is about
subtraction not about submarines mole
and multiply same thing index lined
operations div divide
also about index lined operations
because pandas is built on a numpy and d
array which is a restricted computation
domain and a raw view of interpreted or
an interpretive view of raw memory
the division scenario that we had in
python 2 where there was a difference
between dividing to floats into ins
reoccurs in the numpy and pandas
universe and so numpy and pandas make it
explicit whether you want to do a
regular division or a floor division or
an explicit two division things like
power
are basically exponentiation you can see
here oh yeah if i had two columns and i
wanted to exponentiate the price column
by one thing and the volume column by
something else i'd want to align the
series on its rows
on its index against the data frame on
its columns same thing with modulo
other operations like dot
basically dot is a multiply and a sum
again index aligned
operations like your comparison
operations all of them are index aligned
they all just match up something on the
index and c is the corresponding value
the corresponding index equal to the
corresponding value the corresponding is
not equal to or what not they're all
index aware operations
if i have two data frames df1 and df2 a
line
just tells me how they would be aligned
so if i have df1 and df2 you can see a
line is just telling me what the
result's going to be if i try to align
these and so it's maybe like our
broadcast too our way to peek into what
an operation will perform and i can
choose whether that alignment is done
only on the index or only on the column
just if i'm curious oh if i align these
just on the index what do i get if i
align these just like columns what do i
get dot join is basically taking that
alignment and joining two structures
laterally taking the columns of one
against the columns of the other
and so
it uses the index by default and it has
this l suffix so if the columns happen
to overlap you can figure out which
column is which i actually don't think
that that's a particularly good part of
this api but that's what it is
you can control how that joining is done
just like in sql inner joins left joins
right joins outer joins and merge is
just a generalization of this joint idea
i don't think the join should take the
suffixes i think what the join should
actually be
is
you take one of the data frames
and you do a set axis to add another
layer
to the multi-index that is the columns
and
that gives you oops
that gives you this
that
it gives you one more layer there you do
the other to the other side then you
join them if you join things with multi
uh with multi-index column axes you can
see it joined nicely you can see where
the a is and the b is for each of the
two sides and then once you have that
then
you can rename what this axis is so you
know oh that's the side the left and the
right is the side and a b a b that's the
columns and then you can do group by
operations across the columns
to
explicitly identify oh do i want the max
of one side maximus i think that's how
join really should have worked it
shouldn't have taken a suffix it should
have created a multi-index instead
abs oh absolute values obvious it's just
going to take every value in there and
it's going to compute the absolute value
and there's a lot of these operations
just perform on every corresponding
appropriate numerical value so abs or
clip
and just going to every value and
clipping them by something or absolute
value by something
and that's maybe not index aware things
like min
are index aware they're indexed around
the columns it's going to give you a
result that is the indexing four
whatever the columns were unless you
specify the index on a different axis
and it's going to be the indexing of
where the other axis was so if you do a
min on the column a min reducing the
columns what you get is the original
the original indexing of the structure
and the minimum value going across each
column
if you do a min
on the index the rows it gives you the
original indexing of the columns with
the min down those columns for each
individual
column
and the default is usually operating
down same thing with max
same thing with sum prod and product
same thing with any and all same thing
with mean standard deviation variance
same thing with curt kurtosis and skew
for median the same idea
the indexing of this result is going to
be the indexing of the
axis
against which you operate so if you
operate on the on the
uh
if you operate it
against the row axis then that'll be the
indexing if your options will call them
access that'll be the indexing mode is a
little bit different because mode gives
you the most common values and if there
are ties it will give you those values
here here this is a range index but this
range index makes sense because that's
the zeroth most common that's the first
second third fourth and so far most
common value
and so you can see there's a lot of
nands that index align this back
together you can do some very
nonsensical things like do a mode on the
columns here but we'll skip that count
just count the number of values on a
particular axis just like min and max n
unique count the number of unique values
same thing mad i'm so mad that i didn't
realize the index was what it was that's
what mad does it reminds you that you
should be mad that you didn't pay more
attention to the index when you first
started using pandas value counts
just counts the number of unique values
this is a multi
this is um
this is being done on on both of the
columns so this is this is counting the
total
number of times each combination each
tuple of each of these columns appear
and so if you look at the index of this
you'd expect this to be
a multi-index with the values of the
price column and the values of the
volume column
n smallest tells you what's the smallest
value for a particular column
n small is three what are the three
smallest values for a particular column
and when i say four particular column i
mean using that particular column in
order to determine as a predicate what's
the smallest one so n largest says using
the price column what is the first
largest value what's the third largest
value and whatnot and this is useful and
the indexing is useful because
oftentimes it's not the smallest value
in a particular column that you want but
the corresponding value and another
column is two something in a particular
column in other words this line says
tell me what the three smallest values
in the price column were
and tell me what the indexes are for
those and then look up what's in the
volume column what are the volumes for
those three smallest prices
this is where the index is helpful
imagine how much code you'd have to
write in order to do this if you didn't
have an index and you had to
recapitulate the index yourself with a
bunch of for loops it would be terrible
things like index max and index min very
similar
you want to find what the max and
minimum value of that index are and
you're going to use that then go look up
what the actual values are
things like cumulative min cumulative
max cumulative sum and cumulative
product just perform operations down the
rows and you can see here it performed
this operation cumulative minute just
found the minimum value going down now
this isn't particularly useful because
you can see it's mixing tickers against
each other there should be some sort of
grouped operation where you first group
by the ticker and then perform a
cumulative min this should be something
like this group by ticker and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
preserve the indexing so you're going to
take this
series and you do a series that
cumulative min
that's probably what you want the
separating the tickers but largely you
can see this is just a rolling operation
in fact those are largely equivalent to
just expanding operations on this except
there's no expanding prod
and so it's just an expanding window
operation talking about window
operations there's also ewm again this
ewm like any one of these other group by
operations with zeros operations gives
you something that is indexed by the
original structure ewm is going to
preserve the original indexing expanding
is going to preserve the original
indexing
for your operations like shift and diff
just move things around on the index
just move the data but keep the original
indexing the same diff
just move the data
or just do that and perform a
subtraction as well rolling
just
give me three windowed values preserve
the original indexing or not depending
on what kind of rolling we do but
actually it'll preserve it'll always
preserve the original indexing it'll
always preserve the original indexing
because it'll look at three rows here
and it doesn't know how to collapse
those into a single value but here's a
rolling another grouping operation group
by you do a mean
that just preserves the index or it
creates the indexing based off what
you're grouping by group by ag same
thing this is just a built-in function
this is a user-defined function group by
transform preserve the original indexing
group by transform with an eye lock
preserve the original entity and then
look at what the result is group by ag
operate on a series all by itself
you know preserve the a and set change
the indexing of the result to whatever
you're grouping by resample
well resample doesn't work on this
because it's not a daytime index
resample telling out what level of that
index to use works but this is like a
group by where you're grouping it by
the resampled index and so probably what
you want to do here is something that
first groups by the ticker and then
raise samples in that preserving the
original outer indexing so you can do
further index operations
if you can see from this very tedious
walkthrough of almost all of the
operations on a panda's data frame they
all have some relationship to index or
either index aware they either operate
on the index they either move data in or
out of the index from one of the two
indices everything comes back to the
index and the end and rather than
studiously memorizing all of these
operations it's probably better to
understand the rules of indexing and
then apply them to the operation that
you need to use and so in conclusion if
we think about why it is that we use
pandas in the first place
is it because we have a container it's a
container type that's less convenient
and more perplexing than a simple list
or dictionary
no because the list and dictionary can't
do what a panda series or a panda's
data frame could do which is that really
nice matching up of things for
operations
with that additional associated metadata
is it for the bizarre errors no because
most of these errors actually kind of
make sense when you understand how the
indexing work is it because we will
constantly want to use adopt values
to force it to do what we want because
we want to constantly do a dot set index
no because usually if we're doing a dot
values or a set index we're doing it
because we don't care about the indexing
but if we're aware of index alignment we
generally don't need to do dot values or
dot cinedex that much it's because we
have all these weird incomprehensible
decisions in the api sure things are
named kind of weirdly in some places but
for the most part a lot of these
decisions like the different group by
operations are in terms of how they
preserve the indexing is it for the
minor conveniences definitely not
because the convenience that the index
provides is a major convenience and is
way more valuable than not having to imp
import something like scipy.stats
is it for the 250 000 lines of
complexity that they introduce to our
lives as a
dependency that could break that needs
to be updated that we have to keep up to
date with
it's a lot of code this is a big tool
and a big project and using pandas is a
big investment into your tools but as
part of that investment as part of the
investment of becoming a pandas expert
understand what the index is all about
understand what index alignment is all
about that 250 000 lines of code is to
support this extremely convenient
extremely sophisticated
index aligned operations on
single
index structures or
collections of like indexed doubly index
structures the pandas data frame and so
why do we use pandas that is for any of
these reasons is it for the index
no it's probably because we have a
coworker 50 000 lines of pandas and then
switched jobs and left us with that
we're not rewriting that from scratch
that's probably why we use pandas but if
we're going to use it we might as well
know what we're doing we might as well
try to become a pandas expert
thank you so much for watching this
presentation i hope to see you in the
follow-up session where we'll take a
look at all of these details and show
you how almost everything that happens
in pendants can be understood in terms
of the index and index alignment but
with that i'm james powell it has been a
pleasure presenting to you thanks
everybody